I've had the opportunity to meet a lot
of people who volunteer to wear a
uniform DoD and I've learned so much
about that culture you know most of us
have colleagues and co-workers and they
have brothers and sisters it's it's a
real and different connection and
because the stakes are so much higher
the willingness to serve to be there for
each other means something as simple as
having each other's backs it doesn't
mean they necessarily like each other or
get along but they always have each
other's backs and I find this
astonishing I had the chance to go to
Afghanistan as a guest of the Air Force
they wanted me to go there and see them
perform their mission and then come back
and the deal was to go back to
headquarters and to simply report what I
had seen to share my insights if there
was anything for them to learn or
anything that they could glean now
everything on my trip went wrong ten
minutes after we landed in Bagram the
base came on a rocket attack the plane
that I was supposed to fly home on we
ended up not being able to fly home on
and we thought we were gonna get stuck
in Afghanistan and the plane that I did
eventually fly home on was not a plane
we were scheduled to fly home on and we
would bring home a flag draped casket
just me and my two escorts were the only
three passengers abort this c-17 cargo
plane with a single flag draped casket
strapped down in the middle of the cargo
bay we flew with we brought him home
flew with him for nine and a half hours
from from Bagram to Ramstein in Germany
this experience changed me it had a
profound impact on me but it was when I
got back home I still had to fulfill my
responsibilities and go back and report
on what I had seen and what I had
learned I went out to the Air Force Base
and all the brass from Mobility Command
was there all general officers and I
told what I had learned that I had
shared what I had seen and I got to the
point where I was gonna tell the story
of the fat that last flight home
and I choked up and I wasn't sure I
could make it through the story and I
started and there's no way if I had kept
talking I would have lost it and I just
stood there completely choked up now if
this was the private sector
somebody would have said don't worry
somebody would have said take your time
but that's not what was said as I stood
there not being able to speak one lone
voice spoke up and he said go on the
underlying message was you're safe the
underlying message was we got your back
you're OK in the private sector we
actually encourage people to hold back
and he was telling me move forwards and
it reminded me of my friend Johnny Quest
who said this is what you signed up for
you have to do this the underlying
message was I will be there with you and
I will be there for you